When in the Course of human events, it becomes
necessary for one people to dissolve the political
bands which have connected them with another,
and to assume among the powers of the earth,
the
separate and equal station to which the Laws
of Nature and of Nature's God entitle them,
a decent
respect to the opinions of mankind requires
that they should declare the causes which
impel them to
the separation.
We hold these truths to be self-evident, that
all men are created equal, that they are endowed
by their
Creator with certain unalienable Rights, that
among these are Life, Liberty and the pursuit
of Happiness--
That to secure these rights, Governments
are instituted among Men, deriving their just
powers from the consent of the governed, --That
whenever any Form of Government becomes
destructive of these ends, it is the Right
of the People to alter or to abolish it, and
to institute new
Government, laying its foundation on such
principles and organizing its powers in such
form, as to
them shall seem most likely to effect their
Safety and Happiness. Prudence, indeed, will
dictate that
Governments long established should not be
changed for light and transient causes; and
accordingly
all experience hath shewn, that mankind are
more disposed to suffer, while evils are sufferable,
than
to right themselves by abolishing the forms
to which they are accustomed. But when a long
train of
abuses and usurpations, pursuing invariably
the same Object evinces a design to reduce
them under
absolute Despotism, it is their right, it
is their duty, to throw off such Government,
and to provide
new Guards for their future security.
We, therefore, the Representatives of the
united States of America, in General Congress,
Assembled,
appealing to the Supreme Judge of the world
for the rectitude of our intentions, do, in
the Name, and
by Authority of the good People of these Colonies,
solemnly publish and declare, That these United
Colonies are, and of Right ought to be Free
and Independent States; that they are Absolved
from all
Allegiance to the British Crown, and that
all political connection between them and
the State of Great
Britain, is and ought to be totally dissolved;
and that as Free and Independent States, they
have full
Power to levy War, conclude Peace, contract
Alliances, establish Commerce, and to do all
other Acts
and Things which Independent States may of
right do. And for the support of this Declaration,
with a
firm reliance on the protection of divine
Providence, we mutually pledge to each other
our Lives, our
Fortunes and our sacred Honor.